hi
i'm lindel from south africa my name is
maria fernanda sierra
and i'm from cartagena colombia this is
tanisha from beijing china
this is pablo from santiago chile hey my
name is jason
and i'm from ireland i'm from moscow
russia and i'm from
milano italia hi my name is kate french
and this is
lolly and we live with my sister and
daddy
my name is nicolas saperwich and i'm
from argentina fun fact about myself
when i tell jokes my kids never laugh
fun fact about me
i am a huge formula one fan a fun fact
about myself is that i'm the fourth
generation to work for my family
business which is 100 years old and
remains based in san francisco
a fun fact about me is i sing in the
acapella group stanford talisman
fun fact about me is i can juggle and it
turns out that
homegrown arugula is like ridiculously
tasty
a fun fact about myself is that i appear
as an extra
in a bollywood movie what excites me
about this journey is to have a whole
year
to reflect on how to achieve more impact
for the causes that matter to me
what i'm most excited about is to meet
and engage with a world-class cohort
at a world-class institution however
there is another reason i'm going over
there
what i want to do is exchange this
for that one thing i am really looking
forward to
is being challenged and stimulated
intellectually
a piece of advice that i have from
having experienced msx in the past as a
partner
is to really know what you want to get
out of the year and to focus
hard on that concentrate on
creating new opportunities for learning
and networking
and learning from each other my advice
for you guys
and honestly also for me is to
embrace this adventure this journey we
are
in an interesting spot as a class and i
think that
um we can still totally make the most of
being on campus so to all of my
classmates who are heading to palo alto
for
what is going to be a very very
interesting year i'm looking forward to
getting to know all of you
and to being on this adventure of what
the class of 2021 is going to look like
and now as you look forward to your
future draw inspiration from your own
past
be fearless be confident dream even
bigger
once again heartfelt tribute to the
class of ms6 2021
i'm honored to be one of you have a
great
day and be happy and if at graduation
anybody asked my advice i would tell
people to have twins
they are the source of all my happiness
they're always well behaved
right guys and they're at the end of the
day ultimately what it's all about
all right who wants to press the red
button
[Music]
you